un césar pour roman polanski etes-vous
choqué vous êtes choqué dit me mohamed
oui message envoyé est clair viol et
viol et viol et vous serez récompensés
on demande aux femmes de parler
lorsqu'elle parle on récompense les
personnes qui ont pu la violer imaginez
le message envoyé aux femmes qui peuvent
subir des attouchements sexuels ou des
hommes aussi lorsqu'ils sont enfants ils
vont se dire que finalement ça ne sert
pas à grand chose et peut-être qu'ils
ont raison au vu de ce qui se passe je
sais pas si vous avez remarqué mais
souvent quand on parle de liberté
d'expression on dit qu'il n'ya pas deux
mais lorsqu'on parle de lutte contre
l'antisémitisme il n'y a pas deux mais
on sait qu'on parle de lutte contre
l'homophobie
il n'y a pas deux mais on a l'impression
que l'ours qui concerne la
pédocriminalité finalement il ya une
forme d'exception quelque chose ou on va
séparer
l'artiste parce que c'est un côté sympa
à côté parisien de l'homme
et quand je vois que des personnages
politiques on a vu mise de l'éducation
dire qu'il sépare l'homme de l'artiste
je trouve que ça envoie un message assez
perturbant et ce que j'ai trouvé un peu
navrant aussi c'est qu'on a des portes
et petit à petit le débat sur autre
chose
na dé porter le débat sur l'absence de
florence foresti à la fin comme si c'est
le sens même on voit les lorsque ces
faits importants néanmoins je pense que
ça traduit tout simplement ce qui se
passe dans notre société
lorsqu'il s'agit de viols ou de
pédophilie minorité finalement c'est pas
l'impression que ce n'est pas un crime
si grave et je pense que le message
envoyé aux personnes et aux victimes qui
le sont bah va les décourager de
finalement parlé enfin j'ai l'impression
en ce moment que plus on va s'acharner
sur quelqu'un romane polanski et plus
aurait l'idée des tribunes
extraordinaire et plus on faire des
cartons donc d'où l'intérêt de se dire
qu'elle est pourquoi est ce qu'on fait
tous et hashtag mitu balances ton port
je suis une victime parce que j'ai le
sentiment que c'est contre productif et
qu'en fait on quand on regarde j'accuse
finalement il ça et c'est un carton
relance qui nominer et et des
récompenses
donc est-ce que la lutte elle se fait
sur les réseaux sociaux est-ce qu'elle
serait pas plutôt dans les tribunaux
avec des peines plus sévères et plus
exemplaires eric naulleau
vous êtes le seul pas choquer il ya
beaucoup de l'adjectif qui pourrait
servir à qualifier ce qui s'est passé
pendant la cérémonie des césar et l'
affaire polanski plus généralement moi
j'en retiens qu'un c'est celui d'
absurde
polanski est un homme qui a été condamné
aux états unis pour un crime
particulièrement odieux parce que je
rappelle que le viol est un crime
particulièrement odieux
et sordide ensuite il a fait une
carrière extrêmement brillante et tout
en étant condamné aux états unis je
rappelle ce fait il a reçu huit césar
avant ce qu'il a reçu la semaine
dernière et même un oscar
donc un homme condamné pour un crime
odieux continue à faire carrière sans
problème est récompensé multi-récompensé
et là sur la base de simples accusations
je parle de simples accusations parce
que moi je ne suis pas juge
la présomption d'innocence malgré le
caractère accablant de ce témoignage
vaut pour polanski comme elle vaut pour
d'autres
sur la base de simples accusations il
faudrait que polanski soit clouée au
pilori alors qu'il ne l'est pas pour un
crime avéré moi je ne comprends pas le
principe première absurde deuxième
absurde qu'est ce que les organisateurs
des césars qu'est ce que les gens dans
le public
qu'est-ce que l'animatrice florence
foresti espérait une cérémonie où
polanski est nommé douze fois est ce
qu'ils espéraient qu'ils n'obtiennent
aucun prix
si on était choqués par la présence de
polanski et je comprends au palmarès et
je comprends qu'on puisse l'être
il ne fallait pas venir il fallait
bloquer tout de suite dire le fait qu'il
soit nommé deux fois je trouve ça
scandaleux
je ne viens pas mais à partir du moment
où polanski à un film en compétition qui
a été coproduit par toutes les chaînes
de télévision et par l'état français
moi je pense que si on accepte ça ce qui
peut être contestées il faut accepter
qu'ils reçoivent une récompense
donc moi le débat n'est pas là je suis
pour que le justiciable polanski le
citoyen polanski réponde de ses crimes
mais je ne crois pas qu'on doive
remplacer le tribunal par le tribunal de
la rue où le tribunal des médias ou le
tribunal des césar ça me semble une
confusion des genres très préjudiciable